so Halloween in this time of year in
October is a time when people often use
candles and so we have here a nice
Halloween candle which we can light and
I've always been taught to do
experiments in duplicate so I have
another candle here as well and the
chemistry of candles is really very
interesting it's in fact the very famous
scientist Michael Faraday wrote a whole
book called the chemical history of the
candle here's a Japanese version of the
same book bit smaller but just the same
we take the fuel which is the wax which
is a compound that is a long chain of
ch2 groups that's one carbon and two
hydrogen Beck's melts to make a liquid
and the liquid then is drawn up along
the wick which is just a simple piece of
like a piece of string and then it burns
and there is an awful lot of energy
stored in the molecules of Wax there's
much more energy in a molecule of wax
than there is in a molecule of TNT when
the west's burns you can imagine that
there's this material burning with
oxygen outside here and in the middle of
the flame there isn't so much oxygen
because it has to get into the middle
and so the color of the flame actually
comes from very hot particles of carbon
you can see this quite easily if you
take a spoon and put it in the flame of
a candle just like this you can see then
you get a very nice coating of here of
the black carbon particles
we're seeing light for just the same
reason that if you heat up a piece of
Wow as it gets hotter and hotter the
vibrations of the atoms give out light
and so it's just because the particles
of carbon are literally red-hot now
there are two other things which are
really quite exciting about the candle
one is that because the wick is right in
the middle of the flame is kept away
from the oxygen and in the old days the
wick grew longer and longer and longer
and candles got more and more smoke from
them so now what happens is that there's
a very clever piece of design that the
candle wick is made so that it is rather
like a sheet of paper and as it gets
longer the end bends over so you can see
over here that the flight candle wick
has bent right over so the end of it is
right at the edge of the flame and so as
it is at the end of the flame it just
burns off so as the flame candle goes
down it automatically trims the end of
its candle so so in the 18th century
before this was invented people had
special scissors and every time every
few minutes perps a reporter now you had
to trim your candle to stop its smoking
but now it does it automatically
now the other thing which is quite
exciting about candles is what happens
when you make them go out so when I blow
it out look carefully and you'll see
what looks like smoke so this actually
isn't smoke but it is tiny particles of
wax which because the vapor of the wax
are suddenly getting colder
it's um solidifies and get these tiny
tiny particles much smaller than a
millionth of a meter formed so now I'm
going to try and do it again but this
time when the wax is streaming app I'm
going to show you its wax by lighting it
with a match so are you ready
watch carefully so as I held them I was
holding match about here and you can see
that the flight the wick is here and so
the flame jumped all that distance to
start lighting the candle again and it
made that jump because it went down the
stream of wax that was floating up from
the wick and of course the wick was
still hot because it's been burning so
once it got to the wick it didn't need
very much heat to start it off very good
thank you okay yeah fine